des résolutions je sais pas moi un
mariage par exemple chaque nouvelle
année c'est la même question quelle
résolution pour le 1er janvier
cette question la télévision s'amuse
régulièrement à la pause et aux français
parmi les résolutions les plus
classiques
faire du sport arrêter la cigarette
perdre du poids en 1969 c'était aussi
beaucoup d'argent
la santé après au moins la motivation
est là c'est déjà ça tout comme cette
femme des années plus tard
déterminé à bien commencer 1993 c'est
décidé je perds 10 kg et puis je suis là
chier mais puis j'entretiens ma forme
prendre de bonnes résolutions
c'est bien mais les tenir c'est autre
chose et beaucoup plus compliqué évitez
les bonnes résolutions
oui elles tiennent une semaine oui voilà
des résolutions qui tiennent une semaine
une journée un mois à chacun sa
motivation
certaines sont même impossible à tenir
n'est ce pas monsieur est ce que vous
pensez et prendre quelques résolutions
il de ne pas vieillir comme lui vous ne
pouvez pas tenir vos bonnes résolutions
faites comme cet homme qui pense avoir
trouvé la solution
lui au moins il ne s'embête pas document
qui veut dire que vous n'avez pas de
défaut si c'est que dès que je vais pas
les tenir les résolutions alors dans un
enfer autre solution celle de raymond
devos en 1994
cette fois c'est décidé pour l'humoriste
ils arrêtent la cigarette pour de bon je
pense que je trouve que c'est pas bon
pour la santé
et quand on fait deux heures de
spectacle il faut être raisonnable
donc je ne fume plus rapide
[Musique]